on s'écrivait de tendre chose des mots
pervers mais innocent et rouge comme
notre sens de les relire ici je n'ose je
tentais de brunet cépages rien à faire
et je le redis 2 arrondit les yeux
remplis de ses courbes d'un ton image on
s'écrivait postes restants
au rendez-vous des
nous sommes rendus au rendez-vous des
sens
logis sont les amours
butin quand tu me griffer de ta plume je
restais tout pas interdit sous sa griffe
encore aujourd'hui ma fièvre en ciel
serait nulle depuis lors sous d'autres
couleurs j'ai battu je me suis fait
battre à gré russell est opiniâtre tu
m'avais fait battre
on sait crir est
or ce taux restant
au rendez-vous des
j'apprends au rendez-vous des sans logis
sont les amants
un jour ma lettre me revint tu n'allais
plus jusqu'à la poste tu avaient déserté
le poste et me l'être partait en vain et
revenez me prendre ailleurs ici là je
changeais d'adressent et m'atteignait
dans ma détresse tous et retour à
l'envoyeur on s'écrivait
poste au récent
des poulets
les
et
comme aucune flamme nouvelle sur cette
cendre désormais si tu vois combien je
t'aime est entre tes ligne se révèle
ceux qui hier je n'ai pas su lire il
faut du temps pour faire un coeur n'as
tu pas détruit par en choeur ce qui est
je n'ai pas su dire on s'écrivait
rocheteau restantes
au rendez-vous des
oeuvre hantée
logés
sont les amours
mais